i'm hanging in there no i mean it's uh
it's really what
are you doing i'm not how are you doing
i do just like that do you use that use
that machine
sometimes i've actually made you spank
me i know i've done that okay
[Applause]
wait a minute oh you don't think that no
that was awesome
i feel that one was as good as the last
one i'll try one more all right then
give me some traction
like in that there's a scene where you
actually beat the crap out yourself and
i hit and i
i we the the blood obviously is fake but
it's sticky
yeah and uh there was all this fake
glass around and it didn't it it ended
up being one of the big
laughs when i kind of came up and there
was all this fake glass stuck into the
blood on my hand and it and it always
got a gasp and it was totally by
accident
have you ever you ever had blood in a
cut in your hand
i yeah i i had my period where i
you know put my hand
you do all that you go to the dance
clubs with people you don't know
i mean i don't make that noise yeah
she was amazing and and she was very
funny because
she wanted actually me to forget about
focusing on my accent so we would
focusing focusing
you can come here any night of the week
darling i'm telling you
focusing yeah don't you say it again i'm
i'm all about it
no can you say it focusing focusing that
is the way
no i say it legally you say it illegally
i'm so happy to be back you know you
were my first ever
talk show talk show play my talk show
yes that too i suppose
do you want to do the awkward pause now
i mean it is about time let's not do the
awkward you don't want to see the
awkward pass
it's so awkward
what do you want to do then i want to
feel comfortable
yeah come over here then
i i'm really i'm good you know to eat
and oh yeah
twice
thank you i'm here to help all right
i like that i like you
yeah i i kind of dropped the ball craig
[Music]
i don't think anyone would mind just
pick it up keep going
you know how you can tell if a man's got
one testicle bigger than the other how
he walks in circles
don't all guys have one testicle
slightly slightly but if it gets too big
you just walk in circles all the time
or you have to go and have it adjusted
by a special doctor that ladies don't
know about
oh but now we know the secret's out yeah
that's
i'm going to tell everyone what you're
going to tell all the girls there's a
special ball doctor yeah
yeah they'll cancel the book clubs for
that one is
that's good in case you need to report
to someone
see when you have to put a microphone on
like that backstage do our sound men put
it on you or do you
do all your no he was in there he
unzipped my back of my dress
it gets very intimate yeah
i got the wrong job here giant hairy
coconut oh
i look or you know what i really like is
the weight of like a hairy ball
yes in your hands
i mean what else am i supposed to say
you see it you like try one of these it
might be more really
kiwi fruit yeah okay kiwi's nice it's
small
it's a little mushy am i supposed to be
telling you what i feel
if you want yeah all right it's very
nice
may i suggest kind of food
squirty yeah you know like cream and
berries and such berries who squirts
berries
[Laughter]
trained athletes oh really do they
oh
oh my god no no they don't no no
like cream cream creams okay but it's
valentine's day so you can squirt
whatever you want
no you can't
[Laughter]
i've been to scotland i went to isle of
skye oh that's very close
yeah oh my gosh it's like it's so
beautiful there yes it is yeah yeah i ca
every time i think about it that's true
and we were i know oh my gosh well i was
there during summer too
so it goes on all night long
see all of a sudden i just went back to
the starbucks
and i was thinking of drinking but then
it was drinking coffee in the starbucks
it's just
sorry but anyway um
i had a nice time with you there it was
really by that i mean well i think you
know what i mean what do you mean
is there something i don't know that
happened there maybe
was i was like conscious
that's a terrible question no that's a
terrible question don't answer that
question
okay was i conscious
now i need to know have you no no
nothing for the police report
no no nothing happens absolutely
everyone was fine okay for me
now you really i really like your
response in this dress i might have to
keep it
i might have to just make it disappear i
i lost it
oops
[Music]
that's an easy access button
that's right but the shoes stay on isn't
it
[Music]
i like this it's got art on it okay my
eyes are here yeah
it feels very exciting i feel like i'm a
big girl like i feel like i went from
high school to college you know what i
mean oh yeah
yeah you know about that oh i know about
big girls yeah yeah
i don't know man i
look at that though that's pretty
exciting have the same all the men in
the world have the same striped
uh socks yeah but but these are tights
this is all the way up i get very cold
how can i be sure that it's tights
do you can you do the jujitsu and the
yoga and such yeah i can
um yes i can i could do a fair amount of
that stuff do you do that in your own
life i mean do you have a
yoga or jiu jitsu well either one um
what about a combination of
what about where a combination of both
um
like
it's a passion for it oh no i thought it
was a kumquat
for a minute it was
right i haven't seen you for a while
you've been off making game of thrones
yes
and i watched the first episode and saw
your bottom you did it wasn't my bottom
it's not your button no i have to cop to
that well
whose bottom is it a lady who got paid
very well to show her bottom
you're saying i've been cheated
really i'll show you later oh that's
what
this is better than cable that is
mysterious no
no i couldn't do it i'm stuck what the
hell am i serious
yes really yes i think you could be
you're you're sexy too thanks that's
because you see my mom we think you have
well
it's interesting though having now not
seen your bottom
but actually it wasn't your bottom i now
want to see your bottom even more than i
did before i saw
if you know what i mean you'd be
disappointed
not as much as you'd be if you saw my
boy
can i just look at this what is this
it's a tattoo has everybody seen it but
me
uh no never do they all know about it
are you allowed to show it yeah
i was just so intrigued it goes it goes
out all the way up there
[Applause]
goes down loose down your leg around you
just keep going i'll tell you when you
hit the right
uh do you want what about this thing
dirty do what we want one of these
okay done oh this is the thing that i
use
when you guys run out of power isn't it
hey